Le
Stanfield oh there's two as Snoop I
played Snoop they had me in some like
platform shoes cuz I wasn't quite as
tall as Snoop so they had Chucks but
they were like high heill kind of Chucks
hard to walk in those things I got the
roll uh in the morning at like 5:00 a.m.
they called me and I had to be on set at
like 10:00 so I had 5 hours of prep time
I just watched all the videos I could
watch of Snoop and just tried to like
really get his mannerisms and it was
important for me to get his voice voice
down and so I just kept listening to his
interviews I met Snoop after the movie
on the red carpet and someone had
recognized me and wanted to bring me
over to Snoop and we got through these
layers of security and there was just
like this wall of weed smoke and then
when the smoke cleared there was Snoop
and I was looking at his torso because
he's actually tall and then I looked up
and there he was leite Stanfield College